the next Bachelor hasn't even been  chosen yet but who cares fans already  know who they want for the next  Bachelorette Amy Schumer the comedian  was on the show Monday night counselling  this season Bachelorette Kaitlyn  Bristowe I love the show I'm a fan of  the show and Kaitlyn's my favorite  person that's ever been on it and I  really am pulling for her and I hope she  finds love and after Amy's hilarious and  heartfelt appearance fans are calling  for her to be the next Bachelorette ABC  Entertainment senior VP even tweeted  okay here is the official offer to Amy  Schumer to become good bachelor ette  just say yes to at least start tomorrow  hashtag drafting and Amy reply saying  here I come hashtag Bachelorette be real  with me